salut je suis Steve Martin j'adore travailler avec
mes deux co-stars dans notre nouveau film la grande
année l'incroyablement talentueux mr.  Jack
Black et bien sûr ils sont très drôles
mr.  Luke Wilson désolé Luke
Oh ce que tout le monde grand fan adore
ça va être majeur
dans quelques heures les retombées nucléaires les retombées d'oiseaux
se sont demandé ce qui a tué votre
mariage avec stefano Surrey tout d'abord
j'étais marié à Bridget
n ° 3 le 1er janvier je suis sorti de  ici vous
réalisez que la phase après la retraite ressemble
un peu à ça super de vous parler
je veux juste faire quelque chose de grand vous savez que
nous avons besoin d'une petite aventure vous faites
une grande année
l'année pour faire toutes les choses auxquelles nous
n'aurions jamais pu courir  en bas, ils
tournent leurs quêtes et osent-ils
arrêter de concourir ils meurent dans la
compétition ultime c'est mon année je
vais faire ma marque ne peut pas manquer le vol
il n'y a pas une autre semaine ça craint
pour lui de cuisiner maintenant de  le réalisateur de
The Devil Wears Prada et Marley & Me
quand il s'agit de comédie venez-vous de faire
une danse de la victoire
non peut-être oui je suis
allé grand ou je suis rentré à la maison vous m'avez acheté des boissons
et obtenu ce que vous vouliez
vraiment vous ne voulez pas savoir  Steve
Martin Jack Blac  k Owen Wilson la plupart des
gens se réveillent un jour en réalisant qu'ils doivent faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent faire, lequel
est le moins cher, c'est incroyable, n'est-ce pas à
moins qu'il n'y ait un quiz gratuit ?